[音楽]
みなさんこんにちは
ただいまご紹介にあずかりました手にすると申します
今日この場で私のことを初めて知った人はどれくらいいるんでしょうか
ほぼ全員ねー
私の第一印象はどうでしょうか
顔の表情身だしなみ仕草を見て御判断されると思います
第一印象は最初の7秒で決まると言われるので
皆さんの頭の中には私のイメージがすでに出来上がっているはずです
どうでしょう
しかし
私の大県酪を見て
私のことがどれくらいわかるんでしょうか
今日は私の個人的なストーリーを少しご紹介しながら
お話ししたいと思います
私が大学にいた4年間
日本の47都道府県の全部回りました
小さい頃から好奇心を教えれ
未知な世界に足を踏み入れることがとても好きでした
大学にいた頃
長期休みがあるたび
アルバイトで稼いだを関連を削って日本のどこかへ出かけていました
最初は
有名な観光地の情報が手に入るので
最初の3年間はガイドブックに載っているような景勝地嫁やてぃに旅に出ました
北北海道
南は九州沖縄まで
息を呑むほど美しい景色や
長い歴史を誇る寺社仏閣にはとても感動しましたが
何か物足りないなと感じたんです
日本中を旅していて
とてもいい思い出になったんですが
なんか違うなという謎の気持ちが残ってたんですね
この謎が残ったまま迎えた
2011年
3月11日
東日本大震災があったとき
私は東京に積んでいました
想像絶するくらいの映像がテレビで流れ
どうすればいいのか分からず一瞬戸惑ったんですが
何とか力になりたいと思って震災から7週間号
ボランティア活動に参加し
当時大きな被害を受けていた宮城県の石巻に足を運びました
たった一日だけのがれき撤去のボランティア活動でしたが
様々な気づきがありました
当時あたらレザー支持というのは
大きなた歴を持ち出し
細かいゴミをビニール袋に入れて捨てるということでした
大きな化できっていうのは津波で流された
田中や車の部分でした
そしていわゆる細かいゴミっていうのは
がれきの下で隠れていた本
おもちゃ
写真
なるといった小物でした
目の前にあって手にとっていた一つ一つのものは
本当はゴミではなく
誰かが愛着を持って使っていた思い出のしがらっていうことに気づきました
一つ一つのものにはたくさんの物語が隠れていたんです
当時の東北の沿岸部はガイドブックに載っているような景勝地どころか
甚大な被害を受けてかなり悲惨な状態でした
しかしとても皮肉なことに
景勝地にはない
大事なことを学びました
ものを見て
物語を知る
ということを学んだんです
物語
という表現は非常に面白い
ものが語る
というまるで全てのものには命が宿って言ってお話ができるような意味合いが込められ
ています
なんだかとても日本語らしい表現ですね
ものは誰かが作ったから存在している
または誰かに使ってもらうために存在している
物語というのは作り手の思いや
伝えての思い出そして作られた場所の歴史や文化的背景を指してるというふうに私は
解釈しています
つまりすべてのものには必ず物語があるんです
しかしものに満ち溢れている
今の中に生きる私たちは
あるものを見ても
その物語に気づかないことが多いんです
私が最初の3年間日本中を旅していて物足りないと感じたのは
溢れんばかりのものに気を取られ
その奥に潜む物語に耳を傾けることができなかったんです
ものを見て物語を知る
悟りを開いた私はもう一度日本の見直そうと思って
今度はガイドブックに載っているようなものねぇ
もので満ち溢れているような観光地ではなく
たくさんの物語が綴られる日本各地へ飛び出ました
新緑の春を迎える3しパワ町で山菜を採ったり
セミの鳴き声が響き渡る夏の陸前高田で
広田ばの眺めながらくつろいだり
紅葉色に染まる
秋のを加えずで食欲の秋を堪能したり
真っ白な雪が舞い上がる下川町で雪の森で散策したりしました
日本の地方にはものが少ないかもしれませんが興味深い物語がたくさんあります
ものを見るだけで
その表面的な価値しか伝わってきませんが
物語を知れば
ある意味本質的な価値が伝わってくると思います
日本にはまだまだ知られざる物語がたくさんあります
私は日本の地方の本質的な価値をより多くの人に知ってもらいたいと思って
2年前に起業し今地方の物語を海外に発信する活動しています
地方のいいところだけを見せるのではなく地域が衰退している現場や
直面している課題もいろんな人に知ってもらいたいです
そして様々な目線からその課題や
から解決について話し合ったりもします
日本各地でいろんな国籍の学生や社会人が地域の魅力と課題を知って
そしてその地域の物語るよう学べるようなプログラムを企画し実施しています
ちなみに
小さいの7週間後に初めて足を運んだ
石巻とはあのはとご縁が巡り巡って
8年経った今私は石巻を一つの拠点として活動しています
こちらは
石巻の diy 家具メーカー
石巻工房で作った小物です
医師と向け公募は震災後
住民が球場待つのではなく自ら
ものを作って復興を進めてもらうという目的で立ち上がった
コミュニティビジネスです
私の活動の一環として国際色豊かな参加者と一緒に
石巻工房の見学をしそして
ワークショップを通してもらったことがあります
石巻工房はただ単純にシンプルでおしゃれで
そして機能性の高いものを作っているだけではありません
震災号イノベーションにで満ち溢れた
生まれ変わった石巻の物語をモノを通して伝えているんです
そう私が伝えたいのは震災の話だけではない
イノベーションのビジター市マッキーそのイノベーションというのは日本各地
そして世界各地で勅命されている課題の解決につながると信じています
私が伝えたいのは既成概念にとらわれない
イノベーションの物語です
そして私が活動している他の地域も同じです
その地域の物語を通してサステナビリティやイノベーションのいろんな人に学んで
もらいたいです
ものを見て
物語を知る
実際
私の活動に参加しなくても物語を身近に
そして日常生活で感じる方法もあります
今度
デパートや道の駅で買い物をするとき
是非その商品の手に取ってその商品の物語を想像してみてください
その商品を作った人の顔
その商品が作られた場所の風景を想像してみてください
そうするとそのものの本質的な価値が伝わってくるかもしれません
ぜひ
この考え方を持ち帰ってみてください
ものを見て物語を知る
もので溢れかえっている現代社会だからこそ
私たちはものが作られたところから使い終わったところまでの物語を知る必要があると
思います
物語を意識するようになれば
私たちはもっとものを大事にするでしょう
そしてものを大事にする人
本質を見抜けるような人が増えれば
この世界もきっと良くなると思います
ご静聴ありがとうございましたあ
[拍手]